sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour examiner
cette proposition de loi qui vise donc à
créer une obligation vaccinale
généralisée contre lacko vide 19 pour
lutter structurellement contre
l'épidémie de comics 19 et sortir
progressivement de la crise sanitaire
que nous traversons la vaccination de
l'ensemble de la population est bien la
seule réponse efficace durable et sûre
compte tenu des limites et des risques
associés à la recherche d'une immunité
collective via la circulation du virus
la maîtrise de la quatrième vague
épidémique provoquée par l'apparition du
variant delta dès cet été sans recourir
à de nouvelles restrictions je le
rappelle montre d'ailleurs bien tout
l'intérêt de la vaccination
depuis le début de l'année 2021 le
gouvernement a lancé une campagne de
vaccination d'une ampleur sans précédent
selon un calendrier priorisant les
populations les plus fragiles puis
certaines catégories professionnelles et
enfin souvent à l'ensemble de la
population adulte est depuis la mi juin
aux mineurs âgés de 12 à 17 ans
aujourd'hui vous connaissez les chiffres
et ils sont satisfaisants près de 51
millions de schémas vaccinaux initiés et
44 millions de schémas vaccinaux complet
ce n'est là rien moins que l'une des
meilleures couvertures vaccinales
d'europe
si ces chiffres généraux sont
satisfaisants il ne faut évidemment pas
relâcher nos efforts et ce sous aucun
prétexte
ni pour vacciner ceux qui hésitent ou
doute encore car certains publics où
certains territoires notamment en
outre-mer reste insuffisamment couverts
ni non plus pour la campagne de rappel
sur laquelle j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir
face aux inégalités sociales et
territoriales dans l'accès à la
vaccination dont vous avez pu l'un
l'autre
évoquer des actions dit d'aller vers ont
été mises en place et ce dès le
printemps pour toucher les publics
précaires ou éloignés du soin plus de
90% des structures d'hébergement social
comme les foyers de travailleurs
migrants ou les centres d'accueil pour
sans abri ont été ciblés par au moins
une opération de vaccination
le principal point de progression
concerne aujourd'hui la vaccination des
personnes âgées de plus de 80 ans qui
reste inférieur à nos attentes
une instruction récente cosigné avec le
ministre de l'intérieur vise à mobiliser
l'ensemble des partenaires locaux et à
faciliter à la fois la prise de
rendez-vous et l'accès à la vaccination
à domicile des actions spécifiques
concernent également les outre-mer et
nous avons eu d'ailleurs l'occasion d'en
discuter ici même il ya quelques jours
la semaine dernière lors d'un débat
organisé par la délégation sénatoriale
et son président le sénateur harnes atom
heart and oh pardon
par ailleurs nous progressons en matière
de rappel vaccinal un déclin de
l'efficacité vaccinale au cours du temps
a en effet était observé vous le savez
en particulier chez les personnes
fragiles face aux variants delta cette
perte d'efficacité s'observe du point de
vue de l'infection et de l'acompte et
une contagiosité mais aussi des formes
graves ducobu 19 face à ce constat et
conformément aux avis rendu par la haute
autorité de santé et par le conseil
d'orientation de la stratégie vaccinale
la france s'est engagée dès le début du
mois de septembre dans une campagne de
rappel à destination des plus fragiles
personnes de plus de 65 ans et personne
comme morbide et immunodéprimées six
mois après leur dernière dose de vaccin
et personnes vaccinées avec le vaccin
johnsen quatre semaines après leur primo
vaccination
ainsi que plus récemment les
professionnels de santé et l'entourage
des personnes immunodéprimées
4,5 millions de personnes sont ainsi
déjà éligibles
compte tenu des intervalles à respecter
entre primo vaccination et rappels et
plus de 40% d'entre elles ont déjà
effectué leur rappelle
la campagne de rappel vaccinal française
et l'une des plus dynamiques d'europe
même s'il convient de l'accélérer encore
évidemment la dose de rappel à croire la
protection individuelle contre les
formes graves mais également notre
protection collective
dans l'hypothèse où notre pays devrait
affronter au cours de l'hiver une
accélération brutale de la circulation
générale la stratégie vaccinale retenue
par le gouvernement a fait toutes ses
preuves en faisant appel à l'esprit de
responsabilité de nos concitoyens et en
mobilisant toutes les énergies
disponibles à ce titre il faut saluer la
contribution de toutes les parties
prenantes notamment les collectivités
territoriales les élus locaux à la
conduite de cette campagne avec le
soutien opérationnel humain et financier
de l'état et en particulier des agences
régionales de santé
nous avons souhaité mesdames et
messieurs les sénatrices et les
sénateurs un équilibre entre protection
de la santé publique et libertés elle en
n'imposant pas de manière généralisée la
vaccination à nos concitoyens il faut
continuer en poursuivant les opérations
d'aller vers en les affinant plus encore
vers les publics les plus éloignés du
système de soins et poursuivre la
campagne de rappel dont le public
éligible va lui aussi progressivement
ses larges aires mais ce n'est pas en
imposant une obligation générale
inapplicable et qui pourrait même créer
nous le pensons a certain nombre
d'injustices
que nous parviendrons à la complétude de
la couverture vaccinale seuls les
professionnels se sont vu imposer une
telle obligation vous le savez afin
d'être protégé de protéger les patients
dont ils prennent soin nous croyons en
effet à l'information à la pédagogie à
l'incitation à l'accompagnement rappelle
les gestes barrière à la nécessité
effectivement monsieur le sénateur
d'effectuer les contrôles des passes
sanitaire de ne pas baisser la garde
mais nous ne croyons pas à l'obligation
vaccinale pour progressiez sur le chemin
de la vaccination collective il faut
convaincre et non forcé c'est ainsi que
nous avons avancé depuis le début avec
des résultats remarquables grâce à
l'implication de tous et c'est ainsi que
nous entendons poursuivre c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous l'avez compris
le gouvernement ne soutiendra pas la
présente proposition de loi je vous
remercie
[Musique]